[Music]
thought you were going to get through
the holidays without hearing from us
about the cabbage patch dolls
wrong the cabbage patch kids craze was
one of the 80s biggest cultural
phenomenons
the gift i want the most is the cabbage
patch doll for me and e.t was on the
scene as these round-faced dolls helped
define a decade
it's kind of funny just going along with
it
the appeal i i really i really don't
think that they have an appeal there was
such a big deal made out of them
a couple of years ago i couldn't find
them anywhere today 20 million cabbage
patch kids have been sold
that's enough for every child from three
to eight in the u.s
and in canada to have one they're cute
before pokemon beanie babies and ninja
turtles
the early 80s started the o.g toy craze
cabbage patch kids are each different as
can be cabbage patch kids
a special kind of love the 16-inch dolls
went mainstream in 1983
and their popularity even landed them on
the cover of newsweek
why are you buying a cabbage patch kid
why
because my children are still excited
about them will my sister want wanted
one
because my granddaughter asked for it
they quickly became the must-have item
for kids holiday wishlist
that's if parents could even get their
hands on one
there are no puppy pounds anywhere it's
like trying to find a cabbage patch kid
on christmas eve 1983.
still hurts huh i had her bed all made
demand for cabbage patch kids surged
before the holiday season
it's something that we all have gone
through as a parent you know this
frantic shopping
and get this reports of arrests and
injuries at toy stores started spiking
around the country
where's your christmas spirit
over 3 million dolls were sold in 1983
alone
and this breakout success led to a
merchandise explosion
i just love everything about them
they're adorable for the better part of
the decade
everywhere you looked there were cabbage
patch doll books
playhouses animated tv specials and even
cereals
just to name a few and i love all the
things that it comes with the birth
certificate
and and they have their own names i did
a television commercial for counterpatch
kids when i was probably
seven or eight years old i remember i
just loved it i have four of them
so it was a big rave cabbage patch kids
continue to populate toy stores
everywhere
heck even jojo siwa has her own doll and
now they're one of the longest running
toy franchises
i thought they were cute i thought they
were cute oh they're
cute but i think they've been totally
overrated
and their headline making debut is now
one of pop culture's favorite eras to
poke fun at
how many of these do you own you know
i'm not married and i'm severely
allergic to cat and dog dander so
i guess you could say these are like my
children
that's a joke i'm fine okay
[Music]